there's been a lot of talk about
recession lately recession 2023 24. i
think there are a lot of people that
think we're currently in a recession i'm
not predicting the end of the world or
an immediate recession but the road
ahead does not look great we've gotten
warnings from top wall street analysts
including deutsche bank and goldman
sachs and even former federal reserve
chairman ben bernanke has expressed
concerns about a recession the more the
fed has to tighten in order to get
inflation down the bigger the chance of
a recession and the more severe it will
be but what does it all mean and what
can we even do about it i'm gonna tell
you how economists know when a recession
has happened point out some economic
indicators that have done a good job of
historically predicting recessions and
tell you what three things average
americans can do in case recession is
coming
let's get into it should americans be
prepared for a recession recessions are
painful they typically involve
widespread job losses increased hunger
and homelessness and even higher death
rates so the question of whether the u.s
economy is really headed into a
recession is an important one officially
a recession is a significant decline in
economic activity that is spread across
the economy and lasts more than a few
months
a u.s recession is determined by
economists at the national bureau for
economic research they look at the
country's economic growth during a
period of time and decide after the fact
whether a recession has started and when
that means there's literally no way to
know for sure that we're in a recession
until after it has been declared that
said there are some solid economic
reports that have historically been
reliable indicators the first is the
inversion of the u.s treasury yield
curve that happened in march and
recessions are typically declared
between 6 and 24 months after check out
my video from earlier this year for more
details on the yield curve and its
ability to predict recessions big name
discount retailers have also painted a
gloomy picture with burlington walmart
and ross all writing down their outlooks
for this year another widely followed
recession predictor is the conference
board's leading economic index the index
is made up of 10 data points that
include employment housing business
orders and markets put together they
have a pretty strong track record of
predicting recessions the index has been
negative twice so far this year
including the most recent reading and
over the all important six month period
the index is flattening out a clear sign
of an economic slowdown ottoman ozil
dirham senior director for economics at
the conference board tells me the
reading suggests we've entered a
different type of economic environment
and are likely at an inflection point
that suggests a slowing of growth but
ozodirum also notes that in terms of
calling a recession we're not there yet
the index would need to fall further and
we'd need to see economic weakness
showing in more of the data but if the
worst is still to come what can you do
about it well the first step is being
prepared that doesn't mean pulling
everything out of your 401k and burying
cash in the backyard it means making a
plan here's three simple things you can
do today first start a savings account
if you don't have one next put together
a budget of your monthly expenses and
find places where you can save
finally create a spreadsheet that
details how much money you would need in
the event of a job loss or financial
emergency and work to put that money
aside
even if all this recession fear turns
out to be hype no one has ever regretted
having a solid budget and some extra
money in the bank the situation reminds
me of a plea from rapper young jeezy in
2008 he said interest rates are going up
seems like no value in the buck
meat price is up to stay
utilities are on their way
airlines are running late
please
let the dollar circulate
that's all for now see you next time